since we brought up chimp Empire let me
ask you about relationships
I think we've talked about relationships
yeah I only date Homo sapiens obviously
uh the morning meditation the night is
still young you are human no but you are
also animal
don't sell yourself short no I would say
listen any discussion on the Hebrew Lab
podcast about sexual health or anything
I always be the the critical Force
consensual age-appropriate context
appropriate species appropriate species
appropriate well can I just tell you
about sexual selection
um I've been watching Life in Color with
David Attenborough because I've been
watching a lot of nation documentaries
talking about inner peace it brings me
so much peace to watch nature and it's
worse than at its best so Life in Color
is a series on Netflix where
it presents some of the most colorful
animals on Earth and kind of tells their
story of how they
got there through natural selection so
you know you have the peacock with the
feathers and it's just such incredible
colors like the peacock has these
uh tail feathers uh the male
they're like gigantic and they're super
colorful and they're these eyes
on on it it's not eyes it's like I like
areas and and they wiggle their ass like
to show the Tails they wiggle the tails
the eye spots the eye spots yes thank
you you know this probably way better
than me I'm just quoting it no David at
least continue but it was it's just I'm
watching this and then the female is as
boring looking as pot like she has no
colors or nothing but she's standing
there bored just seeing this entire
display and I'm just wondering like the
entirety of life on Earth well not the
entirety post-bacteria is like
in at least in part maybe in a large
part can be described through this
process of natural selection of sexual
selection so
dudes fighting
and then women selecting it seems like
it's just the the entirety of that
series shows some incredible birds and
insects and shrimp they're all beautiful
and colorful and just a shrimp Manta
shrimp they're just they're incredible
and it's all about getting laid it's
fascinating like I just
um and if there's nothing like watching
that and Champa Empire to make you
realize we humans that's the same thing
that's all we're doing and all the
beautiful variety all the bridges in the
buildings and the rockets and the
internet all of that is this kind of is
at least in part this kind of uh a
product of this kind of showing off for
each other
and all the wars and all this anyway uh
well there's that I'm asking oh
relationships well right um before you
ask about relationship I think what's um
clear is that every species it seems
animal species wants to make more of
itself and protect its young
with the protect this young is
non-obvious so not destroy enough
um of itself uh that it can't get more
to reproductive competent age I mean I
think that
you know we have a natural I mean
healthy people have a natural reflex to
protect
children
well I don't know and those that can't
wait a minute wait wait wait wait a
minute I've seen enough animals that are
murdering the children sure some other
sure there's even simplicide there like
first of all I just want to say that I I
was um delighted in your Delight around
Animal Kingdom stuff because this is a
favorite uh theme of mine as well but
there's for instance
some fascinating uh data on for instance
uh for those that grew up on farms
they'll be familiar with free Martins
you know about free Martins this is
they're cows that have multiple
um calves inside them and there's a
situation in which the calves will
secrete if there's more than one inside
will secrete chemicals that will
um hormonally castrate the cap next to
them so they can't reproduce so already
in the womb they are fighting for future
resources that's how early this stuff
can start so it's chemical warfare in
the womb Against The Sibling sometimes
there's outright sibilicide siblings are
born they kill one another
um this also becomes biblical stories
right
um there are instances of cuttlefish
beautiful cephalopods like octopuses um
and that is the plural as we yeah um
the internet oh yeah that became a meme
or a little discussion yeah pretty quick
oh yeah and now we just resurfaced it
that's great the dismay in your voice is
so amusing
um in any event that the male cuttlefish
will disguise themselves by as female
cuttlefish infiltrate the female
cuttlefish uh
um group and then mate with them you
know um all sorts of
um you know
types of covert uh operations so I think
that
combat it's like a drinking game where
every time we say covert in a contract
in this uh episode you have to take a a
shot of espresso please don't do that
you'd be dead by the end
um so it actually is just a small
tangent it does make me wonder how much
intelligence covert contracts require it
seems like not much if they if we could
if you can do it in the animal kingdom
there's some kind of instinctual it is
based perhaps in like fear yeah it could
be um simple algorithm if if you know if
there's some ambiguity about numbers and
I'm not with these guys and you know
then flip to the alternate strategy I
actually have a story about this that I
think is relevant I used to have
cuttlefish in my lab in San Diego uh we
went and got them from a guy out in the
desert we put them in the lab is amazing
and they I had a postdoc who was
studying prey capturing cuttlefish they
have a very ballistic extremely rapid
strike and grab of the shrimp and they
um we were using high speed cameras uh
to to characterize all this looking at
binocular they normally have their eyes
on the side of their head when they see
something they want to eat the eyes
translocate to the front which allows
them stereopsis depth perception allows
them to strike we were doing some
unilateral eye removals they would miss
Etc okay
this has to do with eye spots
this was during a government shutdown
period where the ghost shrimp that they
normally
um feed on that we would ship in from
the Gulf down here weren't available to
us so we had to get different shrimp and
what we noticed was the the Cuttlefish
normally would just sneak up on the
shrimp we learned this by data
collection and if the shrimp was facing
them they would do this thing with their
tentacles of kind of enchanting the
cuddle the the shrimp and if the shrimp
wasn't facing them they wouldn't do it
and they would ballistically grab it and
and eat them
well when we got these new shrimp the
new shrimp had eye spots on their tails
and then the Cuttlefish would do this
kind of attempt to enchant regardless of
the position of the ghost shrimp so what
does that mean okay well it means that
there's some sort of algorithm in the
cuttlefish's mind that says okay if you
see two spots move your tentacles so it
can be as you pointed out it can be a
fairly simple operation but it looks
diabolical it looks cunning but all it
is is strategy B
yeah but it's still somehow
emerged I mean I I I don't think that
it's like calling it an algorithm
doesn't I feel like well there's a
circuit there that gets implemented in a
certain context but that circuit had to
evolve you do realize it super
intelligent AI will look at us humans
and we'll say the exact thing there's a
circuit in there that evolved to do this
the algorithm a and algorithm B and it's
trivial and to us humans it's fancy and
beautiful where I poetry about it but
it's because so we don't understand the
subconscious because they want that AI
algorithm cannot see into what it can't
see it doesn't understand the
underworkings of what allows all of this
conversation stuff to manifest and we
can't even see it how could AI see it
maybe it will maybe maybe AI will solve
and give us access to our subconscious
maybe your AI friend or coach like I
think Andreessen and others are are
arguing is going to happen at some point
it's going to say Hey you know Lex
you're making decisions lately that are
not good for you but it's because of
this
algorithm that you picked up in
childhood that if you don't State your
explicit needs up front
you're not going to get what you want so
why do it from now on you need to
actually make a list of every absolutely
outrageous thing that you want no matter
how outrageous and communicate that
immediately and that will work we're
talking about coefficient sexual
selection and then we went into some uh
where do we go well and you said you
were excited I was I was I was excited
well you were just saying what about
these these covert contracts and animals
do them I think it's simple contextual
engagement of a neural circuit which is
not just nerd speak for saying they do a
different strategy it's saying that
there has to be a circuit there
hardwired circuit maybe learned but
probably hardwired that can be engaged
right you can't build neural Machinery
out of in a moment
um you need to build that circuit over
time what is building it over time you
select for it the the Cuttlefish that
did not have that alternate context
driven circuit didn't survive when there
was a uh when all the shrimp that they
normally disappear here in the ice
spotted shrimp showed up and there were
a couple that had some miswiring this is
why mutation right X-Men type stuff is
real
um they had a mutation they had some
alternate wiring and that wiring got
selected for it became a mutation that
was adaptive as opposed to maladaptive
this is something people don't often
understand about genetics is that it
only takes a few generations to devolve
a trait make it worse but it takes a
long time to evolve an Adaptive trait
there are exceptions to that but most
often that's true so a species needs a
lot of generations we are hopefully
still evolving as a species and it takes
a long time but uh to evolve more
adaptive traits but doesn't take long to
to devolve
adaptive traits so that you're getting
sicker or you're not functioning as well
so choose your mate wisely